we sometimes swept away by a mood of
sadness that seems to have no cause we
wake up dispirited and listless we lack
energy a direction everything loses its
taste and the smallest challenges feel
unfeasibly heavy we struggle to see the
point of almost anything we are as the
doctors may tell us in a state of severe
depression one of the strangest but most
provocative insights about depression is
to be found in the works of
psychoanalysis that tell us that
depression may not at heart be about
sadness it is a kind of anger that's
been unable to find expression that has
turned in on itself and made us sad
about everything and everyone when we
are in truth deep down angry only about
certain specific things and specific
people if only we could understand our
disappointment and rage more intimately
we could the theory holes eventually
regain our spirits
it isn't existence per se that's let us
down it is a few particular events and
actors whose precise identity we have
lost sight of the theory at once begs
questions how is it possible that we be
both profoundly angry and yet unaware of
the causes or direction of our annoyance
however this lack of self-knowledge is
in terms of our overall mental
functioning not entirely surprising or
anomalous we're endemically bad at
keeping close tabs on the origin and
nature of many of our feelings we can
laugh deeply and yet struggle to explain
exactly why something has set us off we
can find a landscape beautiful a person
charming or a film nostalgia inducing
without having any secure hole on the
detailed mechanics of our responses
understanding has an established habit
of trailing far beyond healing it isn't
just around sadness and despair that we
can be strangers to ourselves but there
is another more pointed reason why we
can lose touch with our anger because
we've been taught probably since
earliest childhood that it isn't very
nice to
angry anger violates our image of
ourselves as kindly and sympathetic
people it could be too painful and guilt
inducing to acknowledge that we may feel
furious and vengeful not least towards
people whom we otherwise still love and
who might have made many sacrifices on
other harms what we're angry about may
also sound absurd perhaps we've been
hurt by the sort of thing that could be
unhelpful II dismissed as small and
which we learn not to pay attention to
because we imagine ourselves as strong
and above being slighted by petty
injuries injuries which wound is
substantially just the same lastly we
might be bad at getting angry because we
haven't seen examples of successful
expressions of anger around us we might
associate the word with volcanic crazed
destruction as dangerous as it's
counterproductive or else we might have
lived for too long surrounded by people
who never dare to raise their voices and
bitterly swallowed every hurt instead
we've not learned the art of a
controlled and cathartic conversation
the way out of this sort of depression
is to realize that its alternative isn't
cheerfulness but mourning mourning is a
useful word for it indicates a focused
kind of grief over an identifiable kind
of loss as mourners we turn boundless
unnameable sadness into much more
specific hurt a hurt about the parent
who wasn't there for us about the
sibling who mocked us the lover who
betrayed us
the friend who lied it isn't necessarily
always an idea to go out and confront
these people some of them may already be
dead anyway but mulling over what's
happened and becoming conscious for
full-scale about disavowed rage and
burden can decisively change our mood
all the same even as specific
relationships and episodes become more
complicated in our minds life as a whole
starts to appear more manageable and
hopeful we're never quite done with a
business of knowing our own minds
you